welcome to camp ET oh my goodness also
yeah I never got to go to camp when I
was little so like I'm really glad this
out okay thank you I have never been to
camp like every ever like I did like ESP
camp and like I know theatre camp but of
course you did I of course I do never
liked her I'd never left home look I
know it was my backyard I mean I started
a YouTube channel does it really look
like I went out in the outdoors in camp
is that stuck in my room absolutely
fight electronic so you never been a
camp but like you have a crazy like
summer story like what's the most
memorable summer of your childhood I
used to go to like a swim team club and
so that's where I like had my first kiss
under a tree and like we would like to
do like swim team I thought I was like
so cool and I fell in love and you know
had my first kiss some of the swim team
and it was just it was the summer it was
a time to be live yes then I went to
high school there's just all in town huh
how old were you when you had your first
kiss going into seventh grade you want
candy oh yeah thank you oh my gosh rings
you didn't see me I thought you were a
today Andy I dividend tonic snacks this
is like a 90s throwback right now and
I'm glad from the past this is the only
thing that's going to my system so far
today so meet you actually you know what
talk about the summer of 7th grade yeah
Usher so let's talk about your app it's
so cute I'm gonna make an app so that
instead of relaunching a website it's
this place where you can go you can you
know like learn about what I wear and
what's trending fashion trends beauty
trends how to get look like it's not
just great sayings advice I started a
dear lauren elizabeth section you can
ask me personal questions so it's it's
almost like creating an inner inner
community of those people that really
really want to get to know me or like
kind of like the things that i pureed we
love your life and thanks for coming
hang out in computers think you're not
to be cheers to you keep on walking I
wonder your first big time I'm nervous
stop you're excited no imma try to hire
Peter jam stop